hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry
so we're gonna do the longest reaction
in God given time we're going for the
record the new like way to prove
yourself yeah reactions aren't enough
you're gonna be longer cuz it's more
authentic so we're gonna watch kung fury
the official short film it's 30 minutes
long let's watch this it looks so real
hey you got a permit for those guns
I've got your permit right here
whoa
whoa
it's a shot really cool
what is happening right now find out
yeah that's my bicep my second babe
hello what are you gonna do my job
Bryson City
really cool
yeah
you
why do this look so good
think about this is like
every time I think it's gonna game over
I'm a cop
and damn good at my job it all began
years ago huh in the line of duty me and
my partner were chasing down a
mysterious cook food master
you're under arrest Punk show us your
head good work dragon you could have
killed both of us with a crazy stuff
like goddamn it
you're the best partner I've ever had
Thanks I learned from the best
you're like a father to me with one
fatal blow hit my partner oh I could
tell it was dead straight off
portable trailer was hit by lightning
and bitten by cobra so images ancient
Shaolin temples and monks mastering the
art of kungfu it was an ancient prophecy
about a new form of kung fu so powerful
only one man can master it the chosen
one when I woke up I saw the kung fu
master running towards me I could feel
my body mutating into some sort of kung
foo freak of nature
hmm you are the chosen one
knock knock who's there
not girls ah because every time I think
this bit is gonna get old and like I
think it's gonna lose me let's see when
I write back I put on a strip of cloth
from the dead go foo master I decided I
would use my new super cut food powers
to fight crime so I became the best cop
in the world and became kung fury really
well done
it's so creative game it's every because
they think clearly no this genre
this is like an Edgar Wright and Robert
Rodriguez were the same guy
I don't want to hear a kokkuri I just
got back from City Hall fifty million
dollars worth of damages and I've got to
mare up I ask like a fire I got my Agra
huh my dog plus blindness to the press
hmm you just destroyed an entire city
block for Christ's sake did you tell me
to pluck it out told you to do it by the
book cut the [ __ ] nobody else in
this apartment gets stopped at a cake
machine and you know it oh listen to me
kung fury you need to start following
the rules like the rest of us so I'm
assigning you a new partner what hell no
we're work alone not anymore you don't
say hi to your new partner triceracop
very nice meeting you recover fury
looking forward to working with you I
work alone either you team up with
triceracop or you're off their case I'm
not off the case but quit
yeah I did the blood it was positive
yeah okay no problem
it needs a poem what what the hell is
this J McNichols bigging it's the ponies
frak you
I need someone to trace that call that's
impossible
not for me it isn't hacker man he's the
most powerful hacker of all time follow
me
see it's like a really skinny I was able
to triangulate the cell phone sing-along
trace to call her his name is Adolf
Hitler Hitler mister worst criminal of
all time no I guess you could say that
in the 1940s if there was a gun food
champion it was something that he
decided to change his name to come come
nearer stop there he knew the come fury
prophecy
I wanted to claim the throne so he and
his posse of Nazi soldiers conducted
experiments for years
we weren't able to figure out Oh master
the art of kung fury and one day it
disappeared from the face of the earth
and no one has seen him ever since until
now I guess he figured if we could find
a chosen one to kill him he would become
confuse
he must have traveled in time in order
to get here it's probably why I
disappeared in the first place so what
are you gonna do yeah my job I'm gonna
go back in time to nuts Germany and kill
Hitler wants a parole so how are you
gonna do that I'm not sure I need some
sort of time machine
wait a minute using an Rx modulator I
might be able to conduct a mainframe
cell layer I can hack the uplink to the
download but Elvis that mean it means
that with the right computer algorithms
I can hack you back in time just like a
time machine
well then attacking time
to the attention of the countless this
serious work
really paint coats bag dresses come here
Oh No
King too much
get back think they'll tell us readiness
they don't it's a problem okay
kind of scary action [ __ ] that's a laser
Raptor I thought the wedding stink
thousands of years ago
who are you my name is barbarian
what Jer says it's the Viking Age
explains the lazer Raptor [ __ ] it went
too far back in time you need to get out
of this valley this place is swarming
with lazer Raptors I'll meet you at the
gods drop katana can help you get there
who's katana I'm katana I can give you a
ride to Asgard
so who are you I'm a cop from the future
I was sent back in time to kill Hitler
but I accidentally went back too far to
this place I know someone who might be
able to help
is that one line gonna fit so me
whoa
that's north
behold it is me Thor son of Odin had
protector of mankind
check out my pecs pecs heretic thanks
bro so anyway Thor this is um kung fury
he's a cop from the future yeah I need
to get to Nazi Germany and kill Hitler
so if you could help or have a time
walk through this portal and you shall
end up in Nazi Germany good luck to you
computing thanks Laura
well looks like this is my right hey
future cop there you go
you know what
here take my number and use this phone
to call me it's a personal transportable
cellular telephone it features 600
channel capacity 10 numbers Vida and an
electronic security lock this revolution
in communication could make it possible
for more more people to have a phone in
their car they just do every situation I
love this film dude it's so creative
i'ma start a healthcare wait I've seen
that kind of 3 where I'm rockin a black
cat I don't see the cloak
my name is Stas this is like a artists
chemists are thinking I am this is
auditions - did that ship funded some
Sean's work on the hair loss avoid loose
this in a psych test yeah this is some
the world toilet in Yerevan a little in
collection but our rocketbox had in
iRacing moustache mo from mas videos it
accrued this designer audition with us
this is how it this is I know this is a
circus - rhubarb Allah no pastor dr.
this is simple intuitive I remember I
never starts to look sick lining starts
a they must start to put up more and
less intake locator
waste attack oh thank you hahahaha
I am
can I go out to the pool
I'm disarming you
oh here we go oh [ __ ] [ __ ] good
huh
like a video yeah this is doing anything
back there
haha
this is like really cool excuse me but
it's very awesome that's fine okay
it's holding your back
don't know
[ __ ] yoga fury nothing can stop me and
my army upstairs
a fact
got scary yeah
oh okay creeped out cause he's so big
like they do a good job yeah with the
physical makes him seem Oh
tricera-cops
poor guy all right Hitler the gig is up
show me your hand
Megara
have you seen come fury oh no
the cartoon
like crazy sleep
who the hell are you
my name is Cobra I have been expecting
you kung fury
I'm your spirit animal what the hell is
this place
this is heaven I'm afraid you're dead
what but it looks so real
yeah no it's totally real mr. Cobra I'm
a police officer I need you to send me
back to earth pronto I'm sorry I can't
help you with that
euphy you're dead you're under arrest
for obstruction of justice
welder Leben I hacked away all of your
bulletins thank you
Thanks
I want to welcome you and your friends
to Germany we are not so different you
and I
I mean we've both got cool style you
know we read you know so that's good
people that doing news yeah check it out
yeah yeah what killing people I love it
you clearly do too it's that cool join
me we could be brothers also I like it's
almost like we finish each other's balls
Verdi or evil my not much left of him is
the important thing is that he's gone
sorry I doubted you triceracop
you're the best damn pot never at home
fury losing damnit I love you
teamwork is very important in it so what
happens now compute e well I need to
head back to the office looks like it's
gonna be a lot of big work
haha
open the doors off I'm sorry fury I
can't let you do that open the doors off
I'm sorry I can't let you open the doors
come fury
god damn it open the doors I'm sorry I
can't put the doors did anyone ever tell
you not to hassle the hoff 9000 oh of
nine thousand seven of a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
the important thing is that he's gone
game over
wait a minute I've seen that symbol
before
hahaha somewhere
Hitler okay we sever those real name
Oh
I think that's David Hasselhoff I'm
pretty sure that's the actual David
Hasselhoff
shut up for a second
see that was brilliant I loved it yes la
Barthe is very impressive
every is a lot of fun every attention to
detail was brilliant and then when it
started to lose me it jumped into an
animation suddenly and it was like the
perfect timing because it was like
alright like this is something different
that I throw it at me which is what I
needed right now well yeah this movie
kind of or this short you know plays
almost as like a Greatest Hits medley of
anything you would have found in a
bargain bin and a yeah it starts out as
like gruff over-the-top City action
movie then it becomes like the first
minutes of like a rogue cop movie and it
becomes like an 80s like pulp fantasy
movie and then it becomes you know
cartoon and then it becomes a hacker
movie like all that stuff you would have
found in today's bargain bin crashed
into a bunch of sketches that make up a
movie and it's brilliant man it's
[ __ ] brilliant
like the whole time that okay David
Sandberg wrote and directed this movie
also yeah he did like everything for
this film and it's that's crazy you know
it's so inventive just one person huh
this is weird because like so many guys
who do that like this movie is
intentionally unintentionally bad or
it's like a lot of guys just make a
movie that is unintentionally really bad
yeah who write direct you know produced
they're like own indie movie and then
you know they're guys like this who seem
to like get that what they love is kind
of schlocky and are recreating it that
way yeah the commitment to the level of
ridiculousness was incredible it didn't
hold back at all like it doesn't just
throw its best guns at you right up
front do you like escalates you know you
like time travels back too far no it's
like everyone is what happened it like
strings together these sketches by it
like it becomes a different movie every
time they find like a connective story
point yeah it's like oh you went too far
into the past that's like computer
hacker movies always went too far with
some like program they're dying and
that's the perfect way to get him then
into like a fantasy yeah like they
really broke apart all these movies
liquid again just the way the green
screen was so as cool as like it was
cheesy it's unintentionally bad but it
was kind of cool to look at the whole
time is like really cool to look at
it had a lot of style to it well that's
how everything in this movie kind of
worked out for me is like at first I was
like oh it's true like green screen but
then once it went on for a few minutes I
was like oh I get it though like that's
not I don't think intentional
necessarily it probably does also have
to do with their budget but it fits
really well it kind of worked for me
like everything does in this movie where
it's like it took me a while to read to
like fully get pulled into the style and
be like oh okay like a joke would go on
and I wouldn't realize and then after a
certain amount I'm be like oh this is
conscious - this is a joke this is
something they were I thought oh right
and like even just the little details
down to like I don't know if that's his
real accent or not but it he has that
sort of 80s movie like this guy clearly
learned English and like kind of learned
the accent you know like those little
things and it doesn't seem like an
insult to it it seems like he'd loved it
so much you know yeah yeah exactly yeah
a lot of ways so totally I mean this guy
knows these movies backwards and
forwards absolutely and that's like the
only thing I would have cut down on is
like all the humor that came from the
style and this and the stuff they were
referencing was great like cuz they took
all that so seriously and the only stuff
that pulled me out was when they would
like do just putting jokes like putting
jokey jokes like that were just jokes
that weren't related to the you know
style whatever was like hey thanks bro
yeah yeah that was like it now that's a
modern joke yeah pulled me out for a
second but like other than that oh
that's fantastic
yeah racewalking job I remember watching
the trailer for Lee saw the trailer
together and it was [ __ ] awesome just
as a trailer making into this 30 minute
peace thank you so much yeah
congratulations dude you're [ __ ]
awesome that's not to David's jam or
Dini for the attention fro but um if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out Jerry's playlist on this
channel does movie reviews shagging app
and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram or Twitter where if we get
enough followers we can get product
placement for things such as salad salad
companies are great they're nutritious
high in fiber and if you're on its
actual selves you could toss salads too
you know you could just lick the
butthole of a person tossing a salad is
that now imagine looking a butthole
hmm salad